[percussion playing]
Rich, Dave, congratulations.
You've made it to the final.
Good job.
It's a second shot at the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and that
check for $10,000.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to create an iconic
blade from history.
Rich, you got any ideas?
I don't have a clue.
What do you want it to be?
Lightsaber.
[laughter]
Let's see it.
The hook sword.
Nice.
NARRATOR: Long before the hook
sword was featured in films
like "Crouching
Tiger, Hidden Dragon,"
it was wielded by the Shaolin
monks in ancient China.
Established around 495
AD, the Shaolin monastery
was a hub of martial arts, where
Buddhist monks were trained
in self-defense using
everything from common tools
to versatile weapons
like the hook sword.
The sword's curved
blade allowed the user
to trip or disarm opponents.
Its crescent guard could be
used to slash or block flows.
And if used in a
pair, the swords
could be linked at
their hooks to increase
the weapon's deadly reach.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck.
[rock music playing]
All right, let's get to work.
Today's day one.
I'm excited to be at my own shop
and have a little more comfort.
In my home shop, I don't
have Will screaming
at me every 45 minutes.
That could be an advantage,
could be a disadvantage.
Ooh, that's hot.
Making this sword is kind
of tough because it's
the Swiss army knife of swords.
It's got a lot of edges.
It's got a lot of
blocking points.
Today, what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to make the crescent
part of the blade,
just to work myself into it.
It's probably one of the
easier parts of the sword.
I'll save the complicated
parts for last.
I like it.
The day two plan of
attack's going to be simple.
Get the main portion
of the sword cleaned up
to bare steel and heat treat.
Looks like it's coming together.
I don't have a quench tank large
enough to do the whole thing.
I'll do two heat treats.
I'll do the main post
of the sword first.
It's straight.
And then I'll do
the hook secondly.
If I do it this way, the
heat will just hit this part.
The big concern that
I've got is overheating
the transition
part from the hook
down into the main
shaft of the sword.
If it's too soft, then on
impact, it can inevitably bend.
And I don't want that.
We shall see.
Right now, I'm
happy about the sword.
And I'd like to get everything
heat treated by tonight.
In order to get the
heat treat right,
I'm going to have to
make a bigger forge.
So I'm going to use these drums
that I got from "Breaking Bad"
and turn it into a
heat treat forge.
Tah-dah.
This is it.
Here goes nothing.
I heard weird sounds.
Freaking beautiful.
Not a single twist or bend.
I think those noises
may have been coming
from the forge barrel
settling, because the heat
treat turned out beautiful.
Today ought to be
a pretty fun day.
Everything's heat treated,
everything's tempered.
Just gotta get a handle
put on it and sharpen it.
It should cut, it should
hack, it should stab.
It should do whatever
they're going to throw at it.
I don't want to see
any failure in this.
It cuts.
I'd say that'll work.
But I'm really not
looking forward
to what the judges are going
to put this thing up against.
Slapping it up against
this or cutting that,
I really don't know.
But you know, we're going
to find out soon enough.
I don't like watermelon.
Today, I'm just
debating what type
a handle to put on this thing.
[bleep]
I ended up going with a wrap.
I never did macrame.
I got the handle wrappped.
I got a little
blood on my sword.
As far as the sword design
goes, it's kind of silly.
It's got a lot of
sharp edges on it.
It seems a little
dangerous to me.
It's sharp everywhere.
Well, it will cut.
We'll see if it will kill.
Blaesmiths, to test the edge
and sharpness of your blade,
I will slash one time on
each of these tatami mats
filled with rice.
If they're sharp, it
should cut cleanly through.
Rich, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Heck yeah.
I think I'm going to do well.
The sword's sharp.
There are no flaws.
There's no inherent
problems with it.
[fast percussion playing]
Nice.
Pretty cool.
Well, Rich-- it is a
light and sharp sword.
You can definitely maneuver
with it for close quarter,
but as you can
see, you can slash
cleanly through these mats.
It definitely will cut.
It will.
Good job.
Dave, you're up next.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[fast percussion playing]
Dave, your blade's a
little bit heavier.
It's sharp enough to
cut, but not sharp enough
to cut all the way through.
Because of the weight of the
weapon, when you're extending
and you have a point
pointing back at you,
there's a little bit of
concern of how you're
gonna be controlling the blade.
But overall, sir, good job.
Thank you.
Rich has a point.
I don't have a point
yet, so it's 1 to 0.
So I have to fare well
in the second test.
Dave?
So gentlemen, to test the
strength of your weapon,
I'm to take two blows against
our terracotta warriors here.
If your blade is strong
enough, it should survive
the impact with minimal damage.
Rich, are you ready?
I am.
OK.
[hard rock music playing]
Well, Rich, wonderfully
light weapon.
Very, very fast.
You've got a little
deformation on the edge,
but it didn't chip.
Picked up a bit of a bend,
but not too far out of true.
Yeah?
Well done.
All right, Dave, your turn.
I ain't going to watch this.
It's not going to happen.
So I'm just using my ears.
[hard rock music playing]
I'm good with that.
When I see Dave's sword
shatter the terracotta dummies,
I'm feeling nervous.
Well, Dave, a
much heavier weapon.
You can see it just powered
right through the terracotta
with no problem whatsoever.
It's still right and tight,
and true, and everything.
Little deformation, but again,
we're hitting terracotta.
Well done.
Awesome.
Rich, David, the judges
have scrutinized every aspect
of your work and your
weapons' performances,
and they've made
their final decision.
David, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion.
Good job.
You're kidding, right?
No, I'm not.
Rich, unfortunately, your
weapon did not make the cut.
Rich, I love what
you brought us.
And during the
testing, you and David
ended up pretty much even.
Both of your blades flexed
during the terracotta strength
test.
But yours kept the bend in
it, didn't come back to true.
So that's why we're
sending you home today.
OK.
Rich, it's time for you
to surrender your weapon
and leave the forge.
Thanks, guys.
I'm completely happy with
the sword that I made,
but right now I feel
a little defeated.
I feel a little beat up.
The first thing I'm doing when I
get home is I'm going to sleep.
I could really use a nap.
Dave, you came in just shy
the first time you were here.
Now you're a "Forged in
Fire" champion who's also
receiving a check for $10,000.
How do you feel right now?
I honestly don't
know right now.
I'm still kind of
elated at the moment.
[laughter]
I like the way the
edge held up on that.
Didn't take any chips
or chunks out of it.
Thank you.
Well, congratulations.
Now I've actually proven to
myself that, yes, I can do it.
And getting to go home
as a champion, that's--
that's pretty cool.
[hard rock music playing]